es el primer día de tregua después de
tres días de hostilidades la jihad
islámica palestina e israel cesaron sus
ataques en una negociación mediada por
egipto según el ejército israelí el
último ataque se registró media hora
antes de la medianoche del domingo
naciones unidas- y egipto pidieron
respetar el alto el fuego pero el grupo
yihadista aseguró que se reserva el
derecho a responder cualquier nueva
agresión la a-2 el enemigo pretendía
acabar con la yihad islámica pero no lo
hicimos por el contrario logramos algo y
forzamos las condiciones por las que
comenzamos la batalla con el enemigo
israel se comprometió a liberar a
nuestros prisioneros
así tan
con un regreso lento a la normalidad los
habitantes en casa agradecieron por un
amanecer sin bombardeos mientras entre
escombros se contabiliza el saldo de
muertos y heridos que dejó el
enfrentamiento más mortífero desde la
guerra de 11 días el año pasado
recibimos la noticia el alto el fuego
con alegría y felicidad volvimos a
nuestro trabajo no queríamos más
derramamiento de sangre y gracias a
dios' volvimos a nuestro trabajo y
abrimos las puertas de nuestras tiendas
de la frontera entre israel y la franja
de gaza está nuevamente abierta tras un
cierre de casi una semana que dejó la
única central eléctrica del enclave
palestino sin suministros de combustible
en el mercado 30 camiones en este
momento es una cantidad suficiente y en
los próximos días esperamos
aproximadamente el mismo número de
vehículos para llenar el vacío
el conflicto inició con un ataque
preventivo de israel en el que murieron
los principales líderes de la yihad
islámica considerados terroristas por la
nación judía eeuu y la unión europea en
la última semana 40 miembros del grupo
islamista han sido detenidos por las
fuerzas israelíes jordania